As a homeschool mom, there are a few things that I always have on hand,
one of them being air dry modeling clay.
I love to use these for so many different activities.
And I found this pack of 24 on the TikTok shop.
It's got so many different colors,
and my daughter is so excited to try these out.
Okay, obviously,
Maverick is really excited to use these two.
So there are 24 different colors,
and I like them because they can really get creative.
Today we're gonna use these as a reading comprehension activity.
We just did a little bit of our read aloud,
and I'm going to have them make the characters,
which are little foxes,
and they're gonna use the mine clay to make them.
I just opened the pack, and it comes with little tools
that they can use to make their creations
and also these bags to reseal.
I was a little bit concerned about this,
so I'm so thankful that they include these.
You can use up the clay and then slide them right in here
so they stay air tight and they won't dry out.
There's also this little users manual
that has different things that they can make,
which I love. And I think the letters is a great idea,
especially if you have an early learner who is just getting
start with the letters. And this would be a really fun activity
to practice letter formation and letter sounds.